brigitte lahaie bonjour bonjour je vous
remercie
ma proposition d'entretien est ce que
vous pourriez pour les gens qui ne
connaîtraient pas vous présenter en
quelques mots et nous dire pourquoi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui alors je
m'appelle belgique est je suis à la fois
comédienne avec un passé sulfureux et je
suis également
l'animatrice d'une émission de radio
depuis 2001 donc ça fait 22 ans où je
réponds aux auditeurs pour les aider à
mieux gérer leur relation affective et
sexuelle très bien actuellement sur sud
radio donc sur sud radio vous avez aussi
écrit des vivres alors j'ai écrit pas
mal de livres oui beaucoup de livres qui
sont des essais sur justement sur
l'amour et la sexualité j'ai aussi écrit
une autobiographie ya très longtemps en
87 sortie en 87 et j'ai également écrit
de trois romans très bien et on va un
peu parlé de votre livre
autobiographique qui a été publié je
crois en 1987 c'est ça et qui a été
réédité récemment
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
de faire des entretiens de philosophie
alors deux philosophies précisément non
mais je trouve que dans je trouve que la
philosophie fait partie de mon émission
d'une certaine manière alors c'est une
philosophie très grand public très
populaire mais oui bien sûr parce que la
philosophie c'est se poser des questions
essentielles sur la vie et moi je sais
que je le dis souvent aux gens
l'importance de donner du sens
alors c'est une manière de parler de
philosophie je crois d'accord alors
justement si vous le voulez bien on va
aborder un premier thème de philosophie
mais pas seulement qui le thème du
jugement
la question du jugement de par vos choix
de carrière de par vos choix de vie
vous avez dû affronter le regard des
autres oui et donc je voulais vous poser
la question en quoi est ce que le
jugement des autres vous affecte-t-il où
vous at il affecté et de manière plus
générale je le répèterai si besoin tout
à l'heure comment est-ce que vous jugez
notre rapport général au jugement des
autres
alors moi je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote me concernant
donc quand mon c'est surtout à partir du
moment où mon livre moi la scandaleuse
est sorti puisque ça a été un succès
médiatique est incroyable
j'avais j'avais des relations aux autres
qui était tout blanc ou tout noir c'est
à dire que ce soit les gens madoré soit
les jambes détester et ça a été une
prise de conscience à un moment donné je
me suis dit bon de toute façon il parle
de il parle pas de moi parce qu'on peut
pas à la fois me détester madoré enfin
je veux dire
et ça m'a énormément aidé à ne plus trop
souffrir du jugement parce qu'on souffre
forcément du jugement puisque on a tous
envie d'être aimé d'être le meilleur
d'être complimente et c'est donc dès
qu'on est critiqués bah voilà après moi
je trouve que
un ami qui vous fait une critique je
trouve ça formidable parce que ça permet
aussi de s'améliorer de voilà mais le
jugement le jugement de toute façon il
est il est souvent très subjectif je
trouve on est subjectif enfin moi la
première j'ai tendance à juger en
fonction de mes goûts et de mes
attirances donc donc je crois que ce qui
est important c'est d'être clair avec
soi même et de sa voix appartement on
éclaire avec soi-même autant qu'on
puisse l'être bien sûr on va on va très
vite sentir si c'est une critique qui
est constructive ou si c'est une
critique qui quelque part par le de
l'autre qui ne nous aiment pas et qui a
envie de manifester sa son désaccord
vous avez dit quelque chose qui m'a
interpellé c'est quand on est jugé le
jugement en dit davantage sur celui qui
juge sur celui qui est jugé oui en tout
cas en ce qui cernes c'était assez
flagrant parce que les gens qu'une
qui me détestaient c'était généralement
soit déjà entré puritains souhait des
gens qui étaient très calé refouler
leurs leur désir est donc une femme
jeune qui se permet de manière
totalement libres d'offrir son corps si
on est très frustrés très coincé c'est
forcément
critiquable surtout quand on a le
larmont de la morale qu'on peut brandir
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose qui
vous a aussi amené à réviser votre
conception de la morale alors moi je
crois que moi j'aime mieux le terme
d'éthique que de morale parce que la
morale et pour moi c'est assez
subjective et d'ailleurs on voit bien en
fonction des cultures et des époques
elle est très variable l'éthique je
trouve bon là ça devient intéressant
parce que je pense qu'on devrait enfin
l'humain devrait avoir une éthique
la même pour tous en quelque sorte une
morale la même pour tous elle est
impossible avec les cultures différentes
les voilà mais moi ce qui me moi j'ai
toujours dit que j'étais peut-être un
peu amoral et en ce sens c'est pour ça
que je me sens très proche de la nature
et des animaux parce que chez l'animal
il ait pas de morale il n'est pas non
c'est bien c'est mal il est dans ce qui
nous permet de vivre ce qui l'empêchent
de mourir et je crois que quelque chose
de très amoral chez moi oui en effet
mais c'est pas immoral tout à fait la
même situation mais on en parlera
d'ailleurs si vous souhaitez on en
parlera j'avais une autre question là
dessus avant ça on sent dans votre livre
qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous agace
c'est l'hypocrisie
ça revient plusieurs fois même homme
j'étais très jeune et un peu rebelle
comme j'ai écris moi les scandales oui
c'était jour d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
j'ai tendance à être plus souple avec
l'hypocrisie parce que malheureusement
on peut pas tout se dire mais justement
c'était le sens de ma question à savoir
qu'est ce qui vous gêne tant dans
l'hypocrisie ou qu'est ce qui vous gêne
et ans à cette époque là dans
l'hypocrisie alors ce que je ne supporte
pas si vous vous laissez les gens qui
vont être hypocrite c'est à dire qu'ils
vont
critiquer ou
juger
les autres alors qu'eux mêmes font ce qu
il critiqué ce qu'ils jugent donc pour
moi ça c'est la mauvaise foi hypocrite
maintenant oui
on a pas vous n'a pas à tout dévoiler on
peut être un peu hypocrite si vous
faites un entretien d'embauché
vous n'allez pas commencer à dire vous
allez en club libertin vous allez si on
vous demande est alors votre vie
affective aubin pour l'instant je suis
célibataire mais je cherche une compagne
j'ai envie de fonder une famille enfin
vous allez être hypocrite parce que si
vous êtes totalement libertin s'est
passé voilà moi cette hypocrisie cette
hypocrisie
un peu police elle ne dérange pas
aujourd'hui hockey et vous avez parlé
aussi dans votre livre je crois que
c'est quand même que c'est la première
phrase
de votre peur de ne pas être aimée et
oui c'est quelque chose qui semble
presque être à la racine de tout le
reste alors à la racine de mon début de
parcours
professionnels oui oui et sans doute
sans doute que c'est pour ça aussi que
dans ma vie affective j'ai toujours
voilà le chien et j'ai toujours su
choisir des hommes qui m'aimait je me
suis jamais engagé dans une relation
avec un homme qui ne m'aimez pas je veux
dire je suis pas maso donc voila mais
mais aujourd'hui j'ai plus peur de ne
pas être aimée parce que j'ai été
largement gâtés et puis je crois que je
m'aime bien je suis très bien avec moi
même c'est ça aussi qui permet de ne
plus être dans la peur de ne pas être
aimée oui ça me fait penser justement
rousseau disait il ya l'amour propre il
ya l'amour de soi et l'amour croix vraie
c'est ce qui peut pousser à chercher
l'amour de l'autre à des comédiens une
récompense ou une réassurance l'amour de
soi nous nous anticipons sur maman et je
crois que quand on est jeune
l'amour de soi c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on acquiert comme ça si
facilement je crois qu'il ya vraiment
moi je jouis situerait autour de 30 35
ans
paix avec soi même
avant on fait des expériences il faut
les faire d'ailleurs moi je trouve que
je trouve que c'est dommage de la vivre
ce désir ne pas de pas se laisser aller
à ses pulsions quand on est quand on est
jeune parce que c'est une c'est une
école de la vie est phénoménal bien
meilleure que la philosophie mais
surtout que suivre des enseignements
ou suivre même une morale
mais simplement parce qu'on l'a reçue
d'un tiers et non pas parce qu'on l'a
vécu et expérimenté par soi même on peut
se demander ce qu'elle vaut hong sang
soo alors réciter un texte qu'on aurait
pas oui oui vous êtes vous avez raison
mais moi je dis toujours qu'il faut la
connaissance et l'expérience pour pour
vraiment maîtriser un sujet moi je pense
que je maîtrise réellement sujet de la
sexualité et glamour parce que j'ai à la
fois l'expérience et la connaissance je
crois que l'un sans l'autre
crée quand même des zones d'ombré et et
risque de nous pousser dans des
convictions qui sont parfois trop
personnel et qu'ils sont et on pourrait
manquer tolède de tolérance et pour en
revenir à votre phrase sur votre peur de
ne pas être aimée
vous la mettez en lien avec votre désir
de plaire quand vous étiez jeune en tout
cas ça a été ma manière d'être aimé de
me sentir aimée pour certaines personnes
ce sera autre chose mais je commence la
question j'avais opposé ce que vous
pensez que c'est un besoin qu'on a tous
plus ou moins à différents niveaux et
qui peut s'exprimer de manière
totalement on a tous besoin d'être aimée
parce qu'on a tous vécu cette première
blessure d'abandon
est la naissance nous en tant qu'être
humain on vient au monde inachevé parce
que sinon on pourrait pas les femmes ne
pourraient pas nous mettre au monde donc
on vient au monde très écorché
complètement
enfin on est un petit animal
émotionnelle qui n'a absolument pas une
capacité à gérer ses émotions et à les
comprendre donc forcément on vit un
premier arrachement quand on sort de
deux semi lieu paradisiaque que ce
paradis perdu l'exacte e mans qui on est
on est pas forcément toujours tomber
dans des familles où on va avoir
suffisamment d'affection etc enfin bref
donc on a on est en manque de beaucoup
de choses et donc on a tous besoin
d'être aimé ça c'est clair c'est sûr
après
on n'a pas tous la même manière il ya
des par exemple on voit bien à certains
artistes qui vont aller chercher la
notoriété la notoriété la reconnaissance
du public par besoin de se sentir aimé
admiré
moi je trouve souvent que les hommes ont
peut-être presque plus besoin d'être
admiré que d'être aimé
il ya une petite différence assez assez
intéressant que si j'ai trop le champion
c'est un truc très masculin sort oui oui
l'homme l'homme enfin de toute façon si
vous voulez que cet homme continue à
avoir du désir pour vous il faut l'être
mirail quoi il faut avoir un regard
admiratif
ce que parfois les femmes d'expérience
et plus âgés perdre et c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont chercher de plus jeunes
parce que les plus jeunes à elles sont à
le regarder beaucoup d'admiration donc
il ya un petit peu une petite différence
la femme la femme elle a besoin de se
sentir désirable se sentir
aimé d'être là préférées
bon il ya une différence comme ça entre
l'homme et la femme mais sans doute sans
doute parce que la mer ne réagit pas de
la même manière avec son fils et sa
fille et de toute façon
une mère est toujours très admiratif
d'un fils pas forcément d'une fille
est-ce que c'est lié au fait que la
fille c'est le même
que l'homme c'est l'autre ou est-ce que
c'est lié alors évidemment évidemment
faire un même c'est pas aussi
exceptionnel que faire un autre bien sûr
et est ce que la fille peut être perçue
comme une rivale une concurrente la
fille va renvoyer forcément plus au fait
que la mère va être remplacé il y à un
moment donné il d'ailleurs on le voit
bien combien de maires essaye de rester
jeune et rivaliser avec leur fille ou
alors le summum c'est quand elles
prennent les arrive à coucher avec leur
beau fils quelle victoire
vous parlez des relations hommes femmes
d'une manière à la fois je trouve le
très réfléchi très rationnel très
pragmatique presque comme une
naturaliste qui analyserait pour le
coude des comportements animaux et un
long mur ajoute une étiquette merci les
gars je vous en prie dans le règne
animal il est a dit qu' il ya des mal et
qu'il y à des femelles et généralement
on admet du même coup qu'il y ait des
comportements de mâles et deux femelles
ou en tout cas des tendances est-ce que
vous pensez que l'être humain malgré ce
qui peut le différencier de l'animal au
sens où l'entend couramment reste un
animal et que de ce point de vue là les
hommes et les femmes ne peuvent pas être
considérées comme étant identiques ont
été gommés pas identiques oui et c'est
tout là c'est toute la problématique
actuelle
des néo féministes qui ont tendance à
penser qu'on est forcément on doit être
identique moi je milite énormément pour
continuer à à a aidé les gens à
comprendre nos différences et notamment
dans les relations affectives nos
différents sons sont fondamentales dans
la sexualité de différences sont
fondamentales et si on les comprend si
on les accepte on va peut-être moins se
heurter à nos différences par exemple
une femme a besoin de communiquer ses
émotions elle a besoin de parler et
l'homme
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il a
tellement envie d'entendre pendant un
quart d'heure vingt minutes et est entre
guillemets jérémiades une femme qui ait
besoin d'exprimer sa tristesse à coller
recettes l'homme lui et plus et plus
dans l'action quand il est en colère il
va aller taper dans un ballon ou taper
son voisin il a besoin d'agir et par
exemple quand il ya une scène entre un
homme et une femme quand ils se
disputent donc
la femme elle va être assise elle va
parler et l'homme si on l'obligé à
rester assis à écouter ou etc il a à son
rythme cardiaque qui accélère tellement
qu'il se sent pas bien et c'est souvent
pour ça qu'il va se lever qui va nous
faire marcher dans le salon et c est la
femme elle du coup elle croit qu'il ne
l'écoutent pas voyez donc c'est tout
c'est que toutes ces choses là si on les
connaît si on les comprend on va pouvoir
peut-être un peu mieux gérer les
relations entre hommes et femmes oui
c'est à dire que ce que j'entends dans
ce que vous dites c'est que on a
peut-être tendance à vouloir rendre
identique les hommes et les femmes là où
les rendre égaux suffirait et que
comprendre en quoi ils sont différents
permettrait les rendre plus
complémentaires et de vivre en meilleure
intelligence oui alors après je pense
que ça va venir tout doucement
bon il ya quand même quelque chose qui
bouge c'est à dire que
sous le patriarcat je déteste je suis
pas contre le patriarcat parce que je
crois que l'humanité n'avait cette
solution là pour survivre mais bref en
effet on va on va passer à autre chose
on a pu mais donc il ya eu des
comportements qui était comme ça très
culturel
la femme un peu plus soumises l'homme
plus un peu plus macho et c'est ça c'est
en train de bouger les hommes sont plus
aptes à pleurer
accepté pleurer les femmes sont plus
indépendantes
donc tout ça est en train de bouger mais
mais malgré tout on reste des femmes on
reste des sommes par exemple
une femme depuis la nuit des temps
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on parle de
femme au foyer elle avait l'habitude de
surveiller que le feu ne s'éteignent pas
tous le foyers de surveiller qui n'est
pas un enfant qui machin de surveiller
bon cesse donc donc c'est nous nous on
est capable de faire deux choses à la
fois parce que parce qu'on a cette
capacité du cerveau vous vous étiez mono
programme mono tâche parce que vous
alliez à la chasse et il fallait être
complètement concentré sur ce que vous
alliez
attrapé ou le danger qui pouvait arriver
et c'est bon et alors peut-être qu'un
jour ça changera mais à mon avis il
faudra encore des millénaires faut pas
oublier la
notre cerveau unis l'a pas il n'a pas
bougé en évolution sont des millions
d'années exactement donc c'est tout ça
qu'il faut bien comprendre et puis quoi
qu'il en soit vous êtes
une usine à spermatozoïdes et nous en a
un certain nombre de bulles pour nous
dans notre ville donc vous gaspillez
c'est quelque chose qui
qui vous pose pas de problème nous on va
être on voit bien des femmes dépensière
mais l'homme est moins apte à gérer un
budget qu'une femme et c'est souvent
d'ailleurs les femmes dans les couples
qui gère le budget de manière plus
raisonnable
après bien sûr qu'il ya des hommes très
féminin et des femmes très masculines
mais quoi qu'il en soit et d'ailleurs ce
qui est toujours intéressant
quand un chef d'entreprise comprends ça
ils aiment bien avoir dans dans dans les
personnes qui vont être un petit peu en
dessous de lui mais à haut niveau il
aime bien mélanger hommes et femmes
parce que justement ça apporte un peu
les grid
oui donc je confirme vraiment que je le
trouve chez vous une approche
naturaliste au centre on disait
d'autrefois les biologistes ont les
appeler comme ça c'est à dire l'idée que
le biologique déterminent en grande
partie le psychologique est ce que vous
disiez sur par exemple le fait que
l'homme produisent des millions de
spermatozoïdes tous les jours la femme
produit un ovule par mois donc on est
déjà configuré biologiquement pour ainsi
dire ou bien sûr à
avoir un rapport au réel qui est
totalement différent et donc que ce
n'est pas absurde d'un point de vue
purement logique et rationnel de déduire
qu'il ya les différences psychologiques
entre hommes et femmes de ce simple fait
de la différence biologique oui et puis
à cela s'ajoutent des différences
hormonales on sait que c'est la
testostérone qui est l'hormone du désir
qui est de la pulsion plus encore que du
désir l'homme
adolescents qui avaient des poussées
hormonales de testostérone bah oui bande
comme un âne c'est quelque chose qui est
que tous les adolescents ont connu et
c'est pas le cas d'une femme nous on a
aussi des pulsions bien sûr mais on n'a
pas cette cette sorte de pulsion qui
prend comme ça de manière totalement dit
ça râle alors vous vous êtes intéressé à
la psychanalyse est affreux 2
part que freud en vacances young aussi
c'est important parce que j'ai une
dimension importante niveau spirituel ce
qui n'est pas le cas de chez freud est
justement parce que là j'allais vous
poser une question peut-être un peu plus
tard à terre c'est la question du tabou
freud parle du tabou le tabou c'est le
fondement de la civilisation
il interdit et puis au sens courant à
kaboul c'est un interdit social ou un
interdit moral ou personnelles aussi
personnelle c'est vraiment et donc je
vais vous demander est-ce que selon vous
tous les tabous se valent est ce qu'il
ya des bons à bout des mauvais tabou est
ce que certains ne sont pas plus nocif
que bénéfique ça peut être conçu de la
sexualité mais pas forcément donc qu'est
ce que vous pensez du bien fondé des
tables bas il y en a quand même enfin
j'en vois déjà de essentiel c'est le
tabou de
la mort enfin je veux dire on you tube
tu pas son prochain ça me semble évident
et puis je crois qu'il ya un tabou qui
malheureusement est très souvent
transgresser ces c'est le tabou de
l'inceste
et où je dirais même le tabou de
d'abuser d'un de quelqu'un qui n'est pas
qui n'est pas encore mature ça me parait
séparer les deux tabous essentiel brest
grèce souvent très culturelle en effet
ou pas c'est souvent très religieux même
est-ce que vous pensez que la religion a
un problème avec le plaisir
alors je alors là je suis un peu embêté
parce que je trouve que la religion
avait avait quelque chose d'intéressant
et qui était quand même assez
structurants
il y avait des rives très très très
clair
et il y avait là la rivière et on
restait dans la rivière mais on pouvait
très bien quand même sortir de la
rivière on savait qu'on transgresser et
puis après vente ul m'en suis vraiment
on sentait mal avec cette transgression
d'aller souvent on aller se confesser et
quelque part elle
elle et des biens les gens à avis moi je
suis pas une
anticlérical forcené je crois qu'elle
avait elle avait son rôle et je trouve
que la société actuelle très soi disant
laïque n'est pas n'est pas structurantes
pour la majorité des gens moi moi je les
entends les gens qui sont donc a priori
libres de faire leur choix aujourd'hui
en france en tout cas malheureusement il
ya encore des tas de pays on n'a pas ces
choix là mais en france on peut vraiment
vivre la vie qu'on a envie de mener si
on est homosexuel il ya pas de problème
si on est
trans ya pas de problème enfin je veux
dire on a vraiment toutes les
possibilités et pourtant
les gens sont presque plus perdu et donc
c'est en ça que je crois que
c'est important de
normes même si il faut pas
assassiner ceux qui la transgressent
foyer mais je trouve que c'est important
une norme ça permet aux gens de
se mettre dans la rivière et puis de se
laisser porter par le courant et de
passes se se
se sentir paumé et ce sans repères sans
sens oui et d'ailleurs il faut bien une
norme pour pouvoir transgresser la norme
on est bien d'accord donc c'est très
bien que transgresser la norme qu'est ce
que ça peut être excitant voilà donc
jouer vous vous demandez ce que vous
pensiez de notre rapport actuel au
plaisir parce qu'à la fois on est dans
une société qui semble sûr stimuler le
désir que ce soit à travers la publicité
soit travers le cinéma et en même temps
l'impression que ce plaisir et plus de
l'heure de la consommation oui on est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait ce que je
voulais dire on est dans une société de
consommation et aussi de consommation du
plaisir or on sait que un plaisir
rapidement obtenu n'est pas
suffisamment satisfaisant ce qui est ce
qu est ce qui maintient le désirent
rires c'est justement de savoir
savourer la tente et de pouvoir
laisser l'imaginaire aussi
fonctionner le désir immédiat tout le
temps un moment donné hyper hyper deçà
de sa valeur bien sûr ça ça casse le
circuit de la récompense qui fait que
c'est aussi et d'ailleurs on n'a jamais
eu autant de l'addiction que que ces
dernières années énormément de gens qui
tombent dans l'addiction l'addiction
au sexe certes que notamment la
pornographie qui était accessible sur
n'importe quel support mais aussi
l'addiction à la drogue addiction à
l'alcool addiction à la cigarette enfin
aux jeux aux jeux vidéo et la personne
qui tombe dans l'addiction étant la
souffrance elle est plus du tout dans le
désir
d'après vous le plaisir peut-il rendre
heureux et a contrario est-ce qu'on peut
être heureux sans plaisir
si on est maso être ressent plaisir non
je crois que je crois que le plaisir
cc c'est la chose essentielle
bas mais quand on parle de plaisir on
parle pas que de plaisir sexuel je veux
dire le plaisir
de
savourer un bon repas le plaisir de tout
d'un coup quand il ya un rayon de soleil
après une journée maussade
plaisir de revoir un ami le plaisir
d'avoir une bonne nouvelle enfin je veux
dire le plaisir c'est enfin pour moi
c'est la quête essentielle de ma vie moi
je dis toujours quand dans ma vie tout
et tout et bien je me dis toujours bon
ok les la tuile qui va me tomber dessus
et il y en a forcément une qui va tomber
après en fonction de la tuile qui tombe
je lui donne du sens et j'en fais
quelque chose mais bien sûr que le
bonheur total c'est une utopie et
d'ailleurs par peur de la tuile il ya
énormément de gens qui passent à côté de
leur vie parce qu'ils n'osent pas ils
n'osent pas prendre des risques à
prendre des risques c'est aussi elle est
recherchée d'autres plaisirs d'autres
d'autres choses mais c'est aussi risque
risquer de prendre nul oui un échec par
exemple oui c'est là qu'on voit que
parfois la peur fait plus souffrir que
la réalité l'anticipation de ce qui
pourrait arriver alors que tout va bien
au moment où on y pense la peur d'être
quittée fait parfois on ne va même pas
s'engager moi je suis toujours assez
surprise à quel point quand un auditeur
me dit qu'il a peur
donc immédiatement jeudi de quoi vous
avez peur généralement la plupart du
temps ils ne savent pas me répondre à
cette question alors que
là on a donc c'est pas de la peur c'est
de l' angoisse et l'angoissé
quelque chose qu'on travaille justement
en ayant une meilleure connaissance de
soi parce que sinon l'angoissé est en
effet indéfinissable mais on peut rater
des choses par peur de les rater oui
bien sûr c'est l'angoissé de l'échec ce
l angoisse de de réussir c'est parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont réussir c'est
pas forcément non plus grâce aussi à un
poids à porter oui c'est la
responsabilité supplémentaire du
changement ok quand on réussit
on peut on peut retomber
et donc ça c'est pas facile donc tout et
tout est compliqué
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la
raison qui gouvernent main est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est la raison qui vous
gouvernent qui a pu vous gouverner alors
moi je pense pas que ce soit la raison
je pense que c'est nos émotions qui nous
gouvernent et d'ailleurs le terme
l'émotion ça veut dire avancer bouger
enfin chez cube promotion grand moment
pour moi c'est les émotions qui domine
vous savez on le voit par exemple quand
vous essayez de rester moi même je me
suis amusé là pendant des élections en
france récemment c'est au courant et je
me suis amusé plusieurs fois à demander
à quelqu'un à bon tu as voté pour qui et
pourquoi et quand vous écoutez la
réponse c'est soit par colère soit par
peur
soit pas laisser les émotions qui domine
alors après on peut être un peu plus l
écoute de ses émotions et à ce moment là
laissez un peu la tour de contrôle c'est
à dire le intellect réagir mais au
départ c'est toujours l'émotion qui nous
entendent en premier lieu c'est toujours
l'émotion quel que soit le domaine même
au point que parfois le discours qui
accompagnent notre émotion qui est un
discours de raison
c'est une raison qui s'avère telles
émotions dont elle provient tout à fait
et vous le voyez dans l'est notamment
dans les gens qui ont des croyances
comme ça un peu un peu un peu forte ils
vont derrière la croyance souvent aussi
une expérience douloureuse ou enfin bref
et vous voyez bien que les leurs
arguments si vous arrivez à un petit peu
à les déstabiliser dans les arguments
ils vont se mettre en colère oui alors
que pourtant on est censé juste échangé
des idées à ce moment là on est bien
d'accord est ce que le meilleur moyen de
convaincre quelqu'un ou de faire changer
d'avis quelqu'un si tant est qu'on en
est le projet
ce ne soit pas de lui présenter des
arguments mais de créer les émotions qui
vont l'amener à modifier son point de
vue alors moi je peux vous dire quand
j'ai quelqu'un qui appelle et qui est
pas d'accord avec moi
la première chose que je fais je lui dis
mais vous avez vous avez raison si vous
avez raison et très vite rien que le
fait de lui dire vous avez raison il lui
fait parler un peu plus de d'elle-même
et à ce moment là je peux comprendre
et à ce moment là en
partant sur une sorte de d'ecoute
d'elle-même on peut arriver à
communiquer ce qui veut pas dire que je
la ferai changé d'opinion et d'ailleurs
c'est pas moi c'est pas mon rôle mais au
moins il ya un échange qui est tout à
fait possible alors que sinon si vous la
prenez deux fronts c'est pas des changes
possible elle va pas son livre année
elle va va rester arc bouté sur sa
conviction et
éventuellement être agressif et des cons
et dans l'agressivité il ya plus de plus
de dialogue possible mais de toute façon
on ne parle que de soi quoi quoi qu'on
pense me conduisent les gens ne parlent
que d'eux mêmes
quand quand ils vont dire ah je déteste
telle ou telle personne
c'est parce que ça touche une partie
d'eux-mêmes donc de toutes façons on ne
parle toujours que de soi
je sais pas si vous avez lu schopenhauer
non mais j'ai lu un livre où on parle
beaucoup de schopenhauer qui s'appelait
qui était formidable donc je connais
mais je connais la pensée de
schopenhauer mais c'est pas mon prêt ce
serait pas mon préféré d'accord mais
parce qu'il ay l'ajustement des
positions qui ressemble un peu à celle
que vous exprimer sur la nature de
l'être humain ou en tout cas certaine
dimension de l'être humain qui est sa
tendance au calcul et à l'hypocrisie
oumou justement il adore les animaux et
quand son chien faisait une bêtise il
insultait il engueulait en disant tu
n'es qu'un humain pour lui l'être humain
ce qui en fait la supériorité c'est ce
qui en fait pour lui la bassesse c'est à
dire l'intelligence calculatrice oui
mais qui lui permet de se détourner de
sa spontanéité de son innocence et donc
du chemin direct vers la bienfaisance
est alors moi je suis pas d'accord moi
je dirais que ce qui fait l'être humain
c'est cesser sa capacité de de s'adapter
un peu plus que de manière instinctive
l'animal va s'adapter de manière très
instinctive mais donc ça prend ça prend
plus de temps l'être humain a une
capacité calculatrice d'adaptation qui
en effet peut l'aider veulent aider à
mieux gérer sa vie moi ce pour moi le
plus grand défaut de l'humain et la
grande différence entre l'humain et
l'animal c'est l'avidité c'est à dire
que l'animal va tuer ce dont il a besoin
pour manger
l'être humain son réfrigérateur est
plein et continuent à acheter
il à son compte en banque qui de toute
façon
permettra pas de tout dépenser et
continue à vouloir encore à
gagner plus et encore plus et encore
plus pour moi c'est vraiment l'avidité
le grand drame de l'humanité et c'est ce
qui nous amène à
toutes ces espèces qui ont disparu tout
ces problèmes écologiques on rencontre
ces problèmes de l'avidité et c'est en
ça que pour moi la seule capacité
qui permet de ne plus être dans la
consommation et l'avidité c'est quand on
a justement fait un vrai travail sur soi
qu'on est dans le respect de soi même
dans l'amour de soi moi moi la première
jeu quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai eu
trois manteau de fourrure d'état de
bijoux aujourd'hui ça ne m'intéresse
plus parce que c'est pas ça la vraie
richesse la vraie richesse c'est le nier
les amis et la santé c'est
c'est le plaisir d'être avec soi même et
c'est ce que vous pourriez le dire
si vous n'aviez pas cru le contraire
avant alors c'est pas que je croyais le
contraire c'est que ça ces fraudes qu'il
a dit et je la sors souvent cette phrase
je trouve qu'elle est très intéressant
on fait plus facilement le deuil de ce
qu'on a eu bien sûr
bien sûr mais on n'est pas je veux dire
[Musique]
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui de toute
façon
ne feront jamais ne seront jamais
capables de se remplir par autre chose
que des que des biens matériels
qui n'arriveront pas à passer l'étape
suivante de pouvoir se contenter savez
quand on a on a suffisamment fait
enquête quand vous questionner des gens
qui sont
mourant généralement ce qui regrette le
plus c'est de ne pas avoir passé à 7 ans
avec les gens qu'ils aiment donc on voit
bien que la vraie richesse c'est son sa
relation aux autres
est ce que vous pensez qu'on puisse tout
faire par amour
sûrement pas
non sûrement pas vous savez moi je parle
beaucoup de l'amour de soi du respect de
soi je dis souvent et c'est drôle
d'ailleurs quand je pose cette question
tiens je vous la pose quelle est pour
vous la personne la plus importante
pour moi oui la personne la plus
importante pour moi je dirais ma mère
bon ben vous avez tous fous personne la
plus importante pour vous c'est vous et
après peut-être votre mère voyez ce que
je veux dire la personne la plus
importante c'est nous tant qu'on va bien
on va pouvoir faire du bien aux autres
imaginez si vous faites pas attention à
votre santé vous êtes malade comment
votre mère elle va être malheureuse
s'ils font moins ce que vous avez pris
trop de risques vous voyez bien que
c'est vous la personne la plus
importante et c'est parce que vous êtes
bien que vous avez une bonne relation et
votre mère
c'est la première règle du pompier c'est
de sauver sa propre ville pour voir
ensuite sauvé quand tu es dans l'avion
la mer elle doit d'abord mettre son max
masque à oxygène avant de le remettre à
son enfant c'est elle protège d'abord
son enfant
toute façon au moins tous les deux donc
on en revient l'amour de soi et à la
nécessité de cet amour de soi
et respect de soi donc justement par
rapport à la question qu'est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas faire par amour
on n'a pas se faire plein de choses
qu'on n'a pas supporté aujourd'hui
heureusement en tout cas en france
les femmes peuvent tout à fait se
libérer d'une relation qui est
totalement toxiques mais par manque
d'amour de soi et souvent à cause d'une
enfance difficile elle accepte des
choses qui sont inacceptables
quand je pose la question à une femme
qui est en souffrance je dis mais
pourquoi vous rester mais je laime
elle sait ce qu'elle me réponde alors
après bien sûr je continue mais c'est ce
qu'elle me réponde je reste parce que je
les aime et en fait elle reste par la
nostalgie des premiers moments par la
peur parfois de se retrouver seul pour
des raisons matérielles aussi parfois
enfin tourner pour des mauvaises raisons
pour les enfants aussi parfois et
l'espoir qui changent bien sûr
est-ce que vous pensez que le temps nous
fait changer
plutôt que le temps nous fait devenir ce
que nous sommes alors moi je crois que
tous nous fait changer enfin de vous
changer le mot est fort tout nous fait
bouger évoluer et chaque rencontre
importante 1
davin nous faire évoluer notre
conversation on va nous faire changer ce
que vous allez me faire dire des choses
qui vont peut-être me faire évoluer vous
allez entendre des choses qui vont tout
tout tout nous fait nous fait bouger et
c'est pour ça que c'est important de
passes s'accrocher à ses croyances et
ses
convictions parce que c'est à ce moment
là on se se durcit on se renferme une
cuirasse autour de nous et on voit bien
d'ailleurs dans les gens qui ont passé
je veux dire cinquante ans vous avez ce
qu'ils ont
appris de la vie qui quelque part son
antre les messages puis vous avez les
vieux con quoi et puis cela de façon
plus vieillissent plus ça se durcit et
plus il faut magie lui l'expérience avec
ma mère j'ai
bodmer mère suffisamment bonne comme le
dit winnicott mais malheureusement par
beaucoup de choses la lune vie avec
beaucoup de souffrance etc elle était
devenue très dure et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'elle a dû se faire changer les
hanches les peaux le coude enfin bref
tout tout tout et elle a fini par un avc
assez grave et moi je me souviens comme
je vais inviter à venir passer trois
semaines à la campagne pour qu'elle soit
heureuse la première semaine c'était
insupportable parce que elle savait tout
elle était d'abord elle n'était jamais
d'accord sur rien je la laissais
j'attendais et puis au bout d'une
semaine et qui se lâcher un peu et on
pouvait commencer donc quand vous avez
un vieux parents qui c'est comme ça à
cristalliser dur s'il
si vous voulez garder la relation à peu
près en bon état faut faut dire amen et
puis c'est tout
dernière question ça veut dire quoi pour
vous être libre
alors être libre pour moi ça veut dire
de faire les bons choix parce qu'on est
jaloux totalement libre et déjà c'est
accepter de comprendre qu'on ne pas
libre jamais libre vraiment totalement
là aussi il faut les vivre totalement
sur une île déserte à ce moment là on se
rappelle il
ya la gravité ce oui enfin la liberté
absolue totale n'existe pas déjà c'est
la première chose à comprendre et
ensuite on est on est libre de faire ses
choix et
si on a fait un mauvais choix
bien ça me semble essentiel de
prendre ses responsabilités et de ne pas
accuser l'autre
assumer assumer assumer ses choix et en
faire quelque chose de positif que je
crois que je suis un maniaque simple
merci beaucoup brigitte merci
[Musique]